So let's see if we can use the test
and write family of instructions to implement logs. The
instruction we will be using will be the test-and-set
instruction and its parameters are a register and a
memory address, usually in the form of offset plus
a register. What test-and-set does is very similar to
our test and write. In that it checks the
memory location at this address. If the memory location is
zero, we put a one there. And we set our one to one. If the memory location was
not zero, then we just set our one to zero without writing to memory. If
we have such a test-and-set instruction, the log
function for a mutex lockvar can be implemented by
setting our R1 to zero. And then, as long as R1 is equal to zero doing what?